pawn stars has featured some truly rare
comic books over the years
sometimes the hopeful sellers leave with
big smiles and other times they hear
numbers much smaller than they expected
regardless it gives us a valuable peek
into comics history
here are the most expensive comic books
seen on pawn stars
in ponstar's 15th season a guy named
david brings in a copy of the dc comic
superman vs muhammad ali looking for 300
published in 1978 the same year as ali's
first retirement and richard donner
superman movie
superman vs muhammad ali remains one of
the most beloved dc comics of the 70s
why would superman and ali fight in the
comic an alien warlord challenges earth
to a championship boxing match
threatening to destroy the earth if our
champion loses superman and ali fight
for the privilege of representing earth
the match takes place on a planet
orbiting a red star which temporarily
robs superman of his powers so the bout
will be fair
as the superior boxer ali wins and goes
on to defeat the alien champion while
superman
his power is restored destroys the
invading fleet
bye in the pawn stars episode corey
calls toy shack owner johnny jimenez to
the store for an expert opinion
and jimenez says the issue is one of his
personal favorites after geeking out
over the comic and the gaggle of
celebrities drawn on the cover jimenez
values it between 150 and 175 dollars
corey buys the comic for 135 less than
half of the seller's asking price but
david seems happy anyway
in this episode a man named zan brings
in a 1942 moby dick comic book
zan previously tried to give a comic to
his father who collects books about
whales and whaling but apparently comic
books don't cut the mustard so instead
he tries to get 600
out of chumley for it this particular
graphic novel is part of a series of
literary adaptations published by
classics illustrated
between 1941 and 1969 classics
illustrated adapted 169 different works
to the comic book formats including
novels shakespeare plays and even fairy
tales
i just wish i knew about it when i was
back in school chumley calls cgc
grading's paul lynch for a consultation
lich says this particular comic is known
for a rare variant interior cover which
includes what he calls quotes a free
promo kind of thing
unfortunately zane's issue turns out to
be the standard version but it doesn't
go away empty-handed
in spite of the book's dog-eared
condition lynch's estimate isn't far
below the asking price
lynch puts the value of the book at 550
and after some hagglings and lets it go
for 375
in season 11 a hopeful seller brings a
couple of valuable comics to the gold
and silver pawn shop
one of them is 1975's giant size x-men
number one for which he's asking 1200.
he tells rick he traded some original
art for the valuable comic though he
doesn't go into more
detail while marvel's x-men first
appeared in 1963's uncanny x-men number
one many of the franchise's most popular
mutants are introduced in giant size
x-men number one nightcrawler storm
colossus and magic all make their first
appearances in the later comic while
wolverine was first glimpsed a year
earlier in the final panel of incredible
hulk number 180 it wasn't until giant
size x-men number one that we learned
he's a mutant or saw the surly attitude
he's famous for
this kid's crying do something rick
calls paul lytch to grade the comics but
the seller clearly isn't happy with
lich's estimate on giant size x-men's
value
while they agree on the grade the
appraiser puts a value between 550 and
600
less than half the asking price when the
seller says he needs at least
900 dollars for it rick doesn't even
bother trying to haggle and passes on it
entirely
oh i love it when they play hard to get
in the same episode as giant size x-men
number one the seller also brings in a
copy of 1963's avengers number one the
very first story about the marvel comics
team that grew to be a media powerhouse
he asked rick for a whopping 4 600 for
the historic issue
that's the best you can do when rick
calls paul lynch and to give his two
cents the expert explains that the
avengers owe a large part of their
existence to a missed deadline
when writer bill everett fell behind on
his deadline for daredevil number one
stan lee and jack kirby quickly
brainstormed a team featuring some of
their most popular superheroes
thor the hulk ant-man the wasp and iron
man ironically although you could argue
daredevil is the reason the avengers
exist
it took until 2011's new avengers number
16 for old hornhead to join the team
well i guess we're both disappointed
then lych places the value of avengers
number one
barely close to the seller's asking
price between four thousand and forty
two hundred dollars
unfortunately rick and the seller can't
come to an agreement rick offers to buy
it for thirty two hundred dollars the
seller goes down as far as thirty three
hundred dollars and neither will budge
to give you an idea of how many factors
contribute to a rare comic book's price
tag
three years before this scene a high
grade copy of avengers number one sold
for 274
850 none of this makes sense
season 13 silver stash pawn shows us not
only one of the most valuable comics to
appear on pawn stars but one of the most
unexpected
in this episode dan returns with a rare
copy of 1950's adventures of bob hope
number one
after world war ii the popularity of
superhero comics waned
and didn't rise again until the 60s in
that time companies like dc looked to
new directions for comic books including
licensed celebrity titles like
adventures of bob hope most issues of
the series featured hope in a series of
comically crazy calamities similar to
his movies
paul lynch comes by and in a rare turn
of events values the comic at 600
100 higher than zan's asking price rick
seems doubtful the comic will sell
considering that bob hope isn't an
action hero and isn't even a comedian
most younger people would recognize
he haggled zan down to 325 do you know
who bob hope is the price is right
[Music]
while bob hope may seem like a bizarre
subject for a comic book
keep in mind that 109 issues of
adventures of bob hope were published
between 1950 and 1968.
considering most comics don't even hit
their 100th issue these days
adventures of bob hope must have been
doing something right
i'm rich whether it's genuine skepticism
or just his famous poker face
rick rarely seems impressed with comics
but that changes when a woman named
holly presents him with a copy of 1952's
mad number one
holly asked for 2 500 for the comic so
rick calls in paul lytch once again
that's awesome originally published by
ec comics mad released 23 issues before
switching to its more well-known
magazine format
there's some controversy over whether
this change was made to avoid the
notorious censorship of the comics code
authority
or just to prevent writer and artist
harvey kurtzman from jumping ship
regardless of why it stopped being a
comic book lynch agrees that mad number
one is a rare find and values it at two
thousand dollars
holly ultimately refuses to part with it
asking for fifteen hundred dollars while
rick won't go about fourteen hundred
dollars
sometimes a unique bind requires the
gold and silver pawn shop to consult
more than one expert
in season 14 a young woman named lindsay
brings in a copy of 1977 star wars
number three hoping to use the money to
pay for her 4 000
wedding dress what makes this comic
different is that the cover includes
signatures from harrison ford carrie
fisher and mark hamill
to make sure the signatures aren't
forged chumley brings in authenticator
steve grad
he says that not only are the autographs
genuine but he knows exactly when and
where they come from
a 1977 signing at a canadian comic book
shop
he gives an estimate of three thousand
dollars for the issue meanwhile cgc's
paul lich puts his own estimate at
around fifty dollars based solely on the
comic's condition and not the autographs
sadly it appears this isn't the comic
chumley was looking for
lindsay leaves the shop with a comic and
without the money she needs for her
wedding dress
she refuses to take anything below three
thousand dollars while chumley won't
budge about fifteen hundred dollars
we hope she found a more generous buyer
and didn't show up on her wedding day
looking like a scruffy looking nerf
herder
who's scruffy looking in season nine's
i'll be dog gone chumley is transfixed
when a seller brings in a copy of a new
peanuts book featuring snoopy
eventually he pulls himself away from
snoopy's antics long enough to call in
an expert but this time it isn't paul
lich
since his comic was published in a
paperback book and particularly because
it's signed by charles schultz
chumley calls in rebecca romney manager
of bowman rare books of las vegas
she explains that the schultz signature
and lucy sketch are a blessing and a
curse
because of the high number of schultz's
forgeries buying or selling anything
signed by him can be tricky
thankfully for the seller romney
authenticates both the signature and
sketch
she values the book between thirty two
hundred and thirty five hundred dollars
pointing out that it could fetch more if
the sketch was of snoopy rather than
lucy
wait until you get my bill
chumly gives the seller fourteen hundred
dollars for the book which isn't close
to what she wants
but it might be enough for a nice pair
of red bearing goggles
not every superhero fan knows that
spider-man didn't debut in his own comic
series
the webhead first appeared in 1962's
amazing fantasy number 15.
in season 8 of pawn stars a seller named
john brings a copy of this sought-out
issue into the shop although he's
unpleasantly surprised at its appraisal
yeah don't you touch that pory calls in
toy shack owner johnny jimenez who puts
a comic's value at around ten thousand
dollars less than john's asking price
between six thousand and seven thousand
dollars according to jimenez the main
problem is the cover which includes a
prominent santa fe shipping stamp as
well as stains increases
jon tries to get corey to go as high as
ten thousand dollars but the most a big
house will offer is seven thousand
dollars
john's disappointment is understandable
two years earlier a high-grade copy of
amazing fantasy number 15
sold for 1.1 million dollars
unfortunately for him in comic book
collecting there's a huge difference
between mid-grade and high grade
i miss the part where that's my problem
in season 14
restaurant owner tommy brings in copies
of incredible hulk number one through
six
signed by stan lee himself in a story
that will amaze and terrify any comic
book collector tommy says he found them
while he was building his restaurant in
brooklyn
specifically quote in the basement
behind a whole bunch of garbage
i i see this as an absolute win
tommy's comics actually represent the
entire first series of incredible hulk
it only lasted six issues due to low
sales though the hulk would remain in
the marvel universe helping to found the
avengers eventually receiving his own
solo series once again and becoming one
of the most iconic superheroes of all
time
the only problem with the comics is that
stan lee's signature isn't original
tommy met stan the man and asked him to
sign the book several years earlier and
corey wonders if that may have devalued
the rare issues
especially because lee's signature isn't
all that rare so he brings in paul lytch
who puts everyone's mind at ease by
confirming that most buyers would be
thrilled about the signatures
eggshell
tommy wants forty thousand dollars for
the comics and paul roughly agrees
appraising them at thirty six thousand
dollars
cory and tommy can't cut a deal though
corey draws the line at twenty thousand
dollars while tommy doesn't seem
interested in haggling and insists on
his asking price
still the restaurant owner doesn't seem
too disappointed and remains confident
that he'll have another opportunity to
get that 40k
or even more damn check out one of our
newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about comic
books are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one